yeah four things four things you do in  life that changes the relationship and  you have to be mature to be able to  manage it one the moment you have sex  with somebody changes a relationship too  the moment you go into business with  somebody you can be your best friend  change as a relationship three the  moment you travel with somebody and  share rooms it changes the relationship  and four the moment you pay somebody it  changes the relationship goes to another  level Tom and I we've traveled together  God knows how many years 15 years we've  been traveling together Tom and I I need  to point out that we only checked off  three